[Music]
this past summer we were fortunate
enough to team up with bud light seltzer
again we got this not an ad we were
asked to do some content for bud light
seltzer and i thought well do my um my
classic bit to my classic pratfall that
i've been doing
since
uh kindergarten i think it was something
i think i learned from either laurel and
hardy or charlie chaplin or one of those
greats it's your bit now yeah i adopted
it and um i've taken good care of it
over the years you have to stop the door
with your foot and then you whip your
head back as though
you're revealing your secret
david copperfield i was doing that bit
for this bud light selter content i
thought why not i pretended to walk into
this bud light sign
i made the a crucial error which was i
was wearing crocs
i think i might have broken my toe when
i did it just trying to do a funny the
joke was on me because for the next two
weeks i was hobbling and i didn't know
how to tell people
what had really happened you should tell
your children that it's an old football
injury oh i'm going to yeah not that you
kicked a cement block wearing crocs
yeah i kicked the game-winning field
goal
but that's that's as far as my football
imagination goes i'd just be a kicker
my kids wouldn't believe anything
hopefully they wouldn't believe you have
realistic football ambitions
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your realistic dreamer host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is my fellow croc
wearing co-host and brother do you like
it
no no but you often do generally uh
often well
what eight percent of the time
eight percent of my foot where you're
suggesting anything
oh really no oh i would say that's true
of me oh i'd say less than
one percent oh oh oh okay so when you're
up at the lake you don't wear crocs like
most of the time
oh i guess i do too and you're up there
a lot all right care to remind you
can i amend my
guests but maybe they'd be a great
sponsor can we just start like is that
pathetic you know we just start like
trying to court sponsors no no i like
that idea you know crocs have got did
you know this about crocs they've gotten
a whole new life recently i know you
know why justin bieber yeah right we
should tell the story about our justin
bieber encounter
um yeah maybe save it
yeah why not okay um i know crocs he
that's he can make anything popular
justin is that amazing they were they
were such a joke for so long i know same
with uh and then he wears them and
they're cool there's a whole new
like line of them amazing he's a true
trendsetter taste maker yes you know i
had a crazy dream about pete davidson
the other night um
and about what a that he has a huge we
have to cut this out but it's just that
he has such a big dick
he does
that's what the speculation is just
because he gets a lot of girls yeah
that's stupid anyway i don't know i
don't i don't i don't buy that really he
doesn't look like he would yeah but but
i don't i don't like girls i don't buy
the connection that because he dates a
lot of famous people therefore he has a
large penis what does that have to do
with anything uh you should ask i'm not
saying a mansplain well i'm not saying
you'll have a large people i'm not
saying it's um i'm not saying
a little penis isn't a deterrent to
dating a lot of people yeah but i don't
think you're
dating a lot of people requires having a
huge penis so you think the worst he has
like a normal size yeah yeah yeah i
don't i definitely don't think he has a
small penis okay well
yeah that's pretty safe that's a safe
assumption right pretty safe um
why are we talking about um jokes and
pratfalls and in your professional your
potential professional sports career yes
yes well that got sidetracked
what would um i guess i'd be a kicker if
i played football yeah or a long snapper
no no no then i'd have to block oh
that's true imagine me trying to block
one of those guys
um anyway we're talking about jokes and
failed jokes and attempts at jokes
because um our guest today is one of the
best at jokes his jokes are uh
they're like works of art he's an artist
he's a jokey artist that's how much i
value what he does what he does wouldn't
you say like there's an artistic quality
to what they did of course
he is on a show that we've talked about
before on this show called impractical
jokers it was something that we got
really into during the quarantine
um i watched i just binged it
uh sal volcano one of the other jokers
on the show was previous guests yes now
friend of the show so this is our second
impractical joker to be on the show
hopefully we'll get all four yeah we
want to eventually the whole set it's
pretty good i'm excited for the second
one now yeah
and yeah like you said we
watched that show so much during the
lockdown that i felt like
we became friends with those guys i know
they're so i know i know i kind of hate
this word but relatable they're so
relatable yeah i had never met him truly
felt like i have i think hopefully
you'll hear it um
he's just so
easy going and he's a guy that like you
know i was just talking to christian
about how i took the long island ferry
for the first time and um he's a guy
that you just run into i think that's
their appeal you run into him anywhere
on the phone oh yeah i saw you in line
at the ferry you said long island ferry
oh what is it uh fairy i just wanted to
clarify because you kind of stumbled
over the long island part of it okay
i'm i'm tempted to ask misha to cut that
but maybe it's funny i think it's funny
because it's at my expense
yeah that's why i want it cut isn't that
that's arrogant i should not have and i
and i want it not cut because it's funny
that it's at you yeah yes which is a
little mean no it's not yeah i think it
makes for good uh comedy it's funny i
should not have that kind of ego that
somewhat so i trip over words so i'm a
pot so i'm a professional podcast host
who trips over words
yeah but it's natural i think people
like um
you know maybe well we leave
warts and all farts and all right um
anyway speaking of farts and funny
things um our guest today i don't think
we've even said his name yet we haven't
i don't think so oh my god this might be
the longest we've gone without saying it
drumroll please
uh his name is joe gatto
gatto gato uh which means great name
well i think it means cat
in spanish you know who would like that
name bill burr
you know he likes a regular name i bet
joe billy yeah yeah nice strong name joe
gatto yeah bill did a thing christian i
made a christian like a birthday video
and bill did a bit for it and he was
like
what are your parents naming you these
names christian justin what about good
strong like yeah what do you say like
like tim i guess timmy billy mikey joey
yeah
let's get into it
all right we got a good strong name for
a good funny guest uh one of my one of
the funniest to me a god i love him and
his
uh fellow jokers
here he is i hope you feel the same way
the uh also such a nice guy you're about
to hear him why do you want to hear me
talk about it more let them judge for
themselves yes uh okay judges put on
your white wigs and take out your gavels
here he is
the uh impractically funny no sure
joe gatto life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
are we doing this with the masks on oh
no i don't know i should take it i know
yeah um yeah i'm backstage
oh i'm not at all no i'm uh i have
several variants great um i brought my
own again
i need the delta one full assortment i
came in we'll cut this out we should be
i mean it's too soon maybe do you think
so i don't know maybe maybe not for you
this is all great okay yeah oh it's
great
katie's offering joe a lot i walked into
a whirlwind of beverage options that i
was not prepared for okay
i'm so curious i will say that i did
recently have a coffee but didn't want
when i heard you sold it you said it was
an ice cold latte yes that's what's sold
ice cold got it yeah yeah i had a coffee
as well but oh la colombe i noticed you
got you got we do the same thing um you
love free stuff you love benji yeah i'm
all over the place
what do you got i'll endorse it give me
it i don't even care what it is i i just
i honestly like
i like the part of being able to help
brands which is fun yeah for me too
which is cool and sometimes the story is
a line but sometimes they don't and
sometimes they're so off for me because
i'm like i'm like a vegetarian vegan
kind of thing that's true so like all
the meat all the fake meats came at me
all the plant-based was like this is our
boy this is our horse in the comedy
world thank you so much yeah because
they're not many thank you katie thank
you oh okay la colombia i've i've had
these really yes and they're fantastic i
think the ice cold is really what sold
it too it's nice it gives it a nice
little touch you know it's nice i
usually avoid these things because
they're a little sweet for me i
this is not too sweet six grams of
sugar
um but wait what how long have you been
vegan i was i became vegetarian four
years ago
and then i went
full veg i tried uh
i i went uh and i i i dip in and out of
pescatarian and vegan now
what is it about fish what fish are you
do you have a hard time avoiding i love
a good shellfish like a good seafood
tower anywhere yeah you got me i'm in
crab leg that kind of stuff uh even like
a sushi like a sushi you know so i do
that
you know when i come out here it's
always hard because some of my favorite
sushi places are out here joe you do a
lot of uh animal rescue charity animal
rescue work is it was that the impetus
for yeah that was by the way not a fart
i'd like to point out yeah i know this
is the chair that's especially when i
got it yeah not that you would care you
seem like no i'll i'll let you know
because we're in a small room and i'll
i'll let you know but i'm not i'm i'm
all right i've been doing okay
so far the columbia
before i got here so everything's fine
oh good oh i meant to ask you okay i
don't have to ask it was my second
question
when and how was your last bm
covered that was fantastic check that
off isn't that i've heard you guys talk
about that actually i think or maybe it
was sal when he was on the show there's
something about now bats just taking it
just having the best it's nice
and when you know it throws you off i'm
notorious though um
i get woken up in the middle like my
wife gets very annoyed because like 3
a.m i'll wake up and i'll have to go to
the bathroom oh really and number two
yeah we sleep with six dogs in my bed i
have nine dogs so i sleep with six of
them in my bed so it's definitely like a
jigsaw puzzle like to try to get out and
then back in bed so it's without waking
up the dogs yeah oh my because then
they'll wake her up yeah they'll wake up
everybody they do they do all right they
now they know i think they're on the
same time
and they all get up to poo
we all go down the dog run
no one's there probably three a.m
i just have to run to the place yeah is
that hard for your wife is she a
vegetarian she's she's vegetarian yeah
she is uh she's not vegan she she does a
lot of vegan stuff but mostly cheeses
are hard for her um we don't eat eggs
though but i i went to an event that uh
so impressive i went to an event which
really changed my life it's called
thanks living it's this place called
woodstock farm sanctuary who i work with
and i love them my wife took me this
event and they do a reverse where you
feed the turkeys on their farm oh and
then they serve a full vegan meal oh
that's cool i met uh this 800 pound
male
milk cow basically which don't really
exist because they become veal oh yeah
and because they don't serve any purpose
so
uh i met this beautiful beast called
caesar and he walked in and it was like
a
9 foot 800 pound dog super gentle super
sweet and i was like oh my god this
guy's great and then i wasn't really a
big meat eater anyway i did like some
chicken stuff but then i was like i
could probably do it and then i just did
it it was that unbelievable yeah it was
coming face to face come to face face
with it and then i saw the movie um
i saw a vegan movie which you're gonna
have to insert the name of it later yeah
i've got the name of it but yeah it'll
come back to me there's one called
earthlings that i love no it was on it
was about three years ago it was called
uh
mythbusters yeah yeah let's say that
yeah and uh it was like talked about
like all the health benefits of vegan it
really wasn't about the animals and
whatnot but i always ate like such a
disgusting human and it was like the
science behind proving like you could
actually say put some years back on the
clock if like you tried it that's really
compelling so i tried it for like a week
and i got through it and i was like okay
let me try another week and then i
honestly felt the healthiest i've felt
my adult life really and i was like oh
wow i should try this for a minute i did
that for about a year and a half
then i got uh i missed desserts i was
gonna say because you're the hardest
part i you're a huge dessert guy i mean
it's like you've worked it into the show
well yeah it's now it's a business
expense
that's right oh my god so they come they
come to you
to promote stuff like that yeah yeah i
get that all the time too yeah oh i bad
i've had because you're concert for
those of you
first of all if you haven't seen them
practical jokers we talk about it a lot
on the show so if people haven't been
annoyed by us enough to
give it a shot um i would again urge you
to see it it is so funny but um
but yeah that's you're constantly eating
on the show and i i noticed that you had
lost weight um a considerable amount of
weight and was that that was the vegan
well a little bit of mix of everything
because i was up to 225 at my heaviest
oh wow and i was like i i have two kids
and i was like i might want to stick
around for a little bit but i should do
something here yeah and so i just
basically was portion controllable more
so for me because i always was like i
grew up in a big italian household
finish a plate you know that whole thing
and i'd be full and i'd be still eating
the other half of the sandwich and i was
like and one day i was just like maybe
i'll just stop eating when i'm full yeah
and it was unbelievable the change and
that oh when i stopped like trying i cut
out everything drinking besides coffee
and water i used to drink like a lot of
sodas and teas and lemonades and that's
that sort of stuff um i don't drink
alcohol so that wasn't an effect ever
never been drunk and never tried a
cigarette or a drug in my life you're
kidding yes yeah it's all natural crazy
oh my god well now i'm like so curious
to see you on a drug i know that's what
everybody says oh my god why was that
what was that choice what was behind
that choice um i was real geeky growing
up never really got into it uh-huh um
when i was uh 18 my father had gotten
sick and uh he passed away when i was
19. and he always said to me i was a
good guy i didn't have to worry about i
mean i equate that to being like to
drinking and causing trouble so then for
a couple years it was like in my head
like a disappointment factor so
interesting then i went to college and i
was everybody always thought i was drunk
because i was just crazy and fun like i
always had fun i didn't have to deal
with the hangovers i had more money i
always drove yeah
much more present you probably remember
that and then everybody would come to me
to find out why they were in fights with
their girlfriends
you know like the morning news on friday
mornings was great
yeah yeah so it was like
here's what you did yeah she got upset
with you for the wow right but then i
don't mind like all my friends like
drink you know i've been with people
like
stuff yeah yeah she enjoys a beer now
yeah you know
yeah i was a bartender for a while so
that's right so like they i don't mind i
love drunk people i love being i could
be around them it's not like that thing
where i'm like oh like i'm not going to
club till 4am i don't care i'm just
having fun yeah that's so impressive
that's so admirable oh thanks
wow and you said you grew up and
obviously big italian house
you have a lot of siblings then i have
two older sisters okay but i'm one of 15
cousins i'm the youngest of 15. oh my
god it's a crazy little and so you're it
was that on your dad's side that was my
mom's side oh okay yeah my dad's side he
he cut ties with because they fell to uh
they fell into some sort of mafioso
trouble we'll get to that okay yeah
let's save that my father's side my
father had one brother and he actually
uh he went on the lamb
down to uh he went on the land i've
never known anyone who's gone on the
line yeah my uncle had gone on the lamb
he was he was like a small time of
running numbers on staten island oh my
god and he just took money from the
wrong people and then he just left and
went to dc and a guy not this is a true
story a guy knocked on my father's door
my parents were newlyweds they were
living in a one bedroom apartment on
staten island they're married one year
and a guy knocks on the door and he says
uh are you joe gatto yeah it's frank
your brother and he says yeah he goes
you owe me whatever it was you owe me
five thousand dollars i was like i don't
have it he said i'm coming back every
day until you do so they called the
police whatever and they did a
full-blown fbi sting operation no and my
the fbi was hiding in my parents
bathroom of their one bedroom apartment
they got the guy in the kitchen again
real coffee they got him talking the
guys busted out and they they arrested
the guy oh my god wait a minute uh
wait so wasn't your dad nervous that
like to get involved to get involved at
all no not real because he knew my
father like he knew he wasn't in like
any sort of big time wreck was all like
small time staten island like trouble it
wasn't like you know it wasn't the main
families i guess
but he wasn't just not he was also just
not gonna have it so he was like we
gotta solve this problem he wasn't gonna
he was that kind of guy yeah yeah
was he he must have been a fun he must
have been funny he was
my dad's i had the everybody always says
that the best of my mom and my dad
because my dad
had the ability to just say something
just loud enough to make you laugh and
embarrass you because you're laughing
and nobody knows why you're laughing
which i'm the king
but he was super he was kind of dry or
whatever but he was very funny and my
mother was super funny but electric
walked in the room and let it up that
kind of deal is she still no she passed
away uh about nine years ago oh so but
she was here for the premiere oh yeah
she was like she was like the mom she
was like our mascot like you know second
month what was her name her name was
jerry jerry
she was we we actually used to rehearse
in her basement no
the tenderloins formed in the basement
of my mother's house i was that's right
i was crushing it living at home really
third he's killing it uh but she used to
rehearse and she used to like come and
like just like in the other room there's
like an office she'd pretend to like pay
bills and just like listen and laugh so
cute so she was like our mascot and
stuff so it was great and she got to see
the premiere she was like a peacock all
over staten island you know like that's
my son that's my god
that's right joe yes oh man that's
really cool and your sisters what do
they do they're uh
they're awesome one i have two older
ones one is in jersey and she has uh she
has older kids now
and then my other one is out on long
island with me and she had she has 16
year old twins oh wow and then she had a
uh um accident baby
baby yeah uh little joey is our whoopsie
baby he's seven oh wow so they have a
six-year-old daughter that's a nice
bridge yeah that's nice and you're close
enough they can hang out yeah them yeah
and we're super tight we're all together
all the time that's um how long was your
uncle on the lam for is he still on the
way no he passed away three uh months
after my father oh my god they got him
no
my god
i don't even know how he went well i you
know it's funny i was uh thinking about
you in the context of um being able to
laugh about anything like we made
some jokes about i was making a joke
about uh a coveted variant and i thought
immediately felt like oh my god that's
too much i couldn't do and i remember i
was watching jerry seinfeld on comedians
and cars and he said you know comedians
they'll laugh at anything like that
that's their default you can he's like i
expect people to be laughing about
making jokes about me at my funeral um
and i remember
you laughing about your dad's passing
yeah on the show i remember the guys
kind of teasing you about it yeah yeah
and thinking jesus that's gotta be is
that not off limits but you were like
good-natured about it no i get them with
it more often than not
yeah like i have like i've brought in
one of the episodes i don't know if you
saw the one where i brought uh it's the
one where we're trying to make each
other laugh so there's a challenge where
we're trying to make each other laugh in
a waiting room in front of our other
people
elimination so it was down to me in
queue and i had a phone call and i was
like oh and i took a fake phone call i
was like hey oh you're here i thought i
was meeting you guys at the restaurant
and i was like oh okay i love you mom
love you dad and i hung up and i left
and walked out and i said i'll meet you
and i said i'll be right back and i
walked in with two skeletons on sticks
literally punching himself in his face
not to laugh uh does it count if you
how do you if you i've wondered that
about that particular challenge if you
contort your face i mean like you're
guitar don't you do it we have a
gentleman's agreement that laughs a
laugh and you'll you'll admit and
surrender it's more of a surrender thing
like you know that somebody got you okay
because your thing is you you kind of
put your you have you each have a
specific way to like prevent laughter i
try to go dead in the eyes and just hold
my lips together like and that's really
my default
yeah what's the hardest because you also
seem well we'll get into it a little bit
but i um
there's so many things to ask you i feel
like
first of all i should say to people
listening
this is the first time that i've
seen when we've recorded one of these i
haven't been in person with somebody
this is great this is great and i'm so
glad it's you joe because um i said this
to sal as well but um i discovered your
show like at the start of the pandemic
you know when we were like locked down
and quarantined and i just i felt like i
hung out with you for the first couple
of months it was the best it was such a
godsend um so it's really i don't know
it's really it's something very symbolic
about getting to do that oh yeah it's so
awesome yeah yeah it's like like uh
you're not sick of me yet so not at all
not at all in fact i am i'm so glad that
the new season that i've been working in
in bulgaria and i haven't had a chance
to
see the new season i saw the first
episode um but uh and i want to get in i
want to get into it and the challenges
that the quarantine has presented in
terms of doing has there have there been
anything that like you've found it's
been a if anything like a benefit uh to
doing it in this new environment yeah i
think we've had to really concentrate on
new ways to do it which is fun which is
you know you don't really think of new
ways to do it when you come to season
nine right like she's an audience like
go ahead we got it well it's also like
works i mean like even the challenge you
you you mentioned like make each other
laugh in a waiting room it's simple but
it's like still you're still mining such
great stuff
think about all the times you try to
make your friends laugh like you do you
can make it you know you do it every day
or the names or like i love when you
answer the phone you have to like
ask for people's names in a waiting room
um without laughing without laughing
it's so good and and just silly names
really make me laugh and that's one of
the ones you're not quite as good at i
feel like your strength is
um you're you seem fearless yeah just
boldness is really one yeah because the
thing with this comedy that we do is
like the way i naturally made my friends
laugh like these guys were always like
sal was always afraid to like get an
elevator with me just because he knew
something was gonna go down like the
subway like anything close face with me
he would just like hate you know because
he knew something was gonna happen but
like somebody take delight you're the
one that like especially with sal
like his fear of cats let's say i mean
he's like a death like a real
deep fear and yeah it does do you have
this this look of glee sometimes when i
i watch it sometimes that i'm cringing
on sal's behalf but it's you know
obviously fun um but you always seem
like you really take joy yeah yeah i i
do because sal wears it on the skin and
south is a thing where he uh enjoys the
torture a bit with when his friends are
doing it like he does that thing where
he's like stop yeah yeah i know it's
like it's happening but i've always like
sal's always been such a fun target for
me we've been through so much together
um you know and
i've always i've always had a bunch of
long cons with him and my favorite one
it actually got discovered when we were
filming the pilot of the tv show
for for a decade full decade any mailing
list i came across i would put sales
phone number and email on like like
think about how many mailing lists back
in the day right i'm talking about like
you know late late 90s
everybody wanted your email just one i'd
put everything so sal used to get stacks
of junk mail to his house like he
literally once got a
literally once he got a i signed him up
for the uh
the ex
i forgot the name of the pack i'm gonna
say executive but it was like the
executive sample package for
tempur-pedic mattresses
and oh no the craftmatic adjustable bed
oh yeah and they sent him
they sent him a mini to his house like a
mini version of the bed no like i wanted
to like show him how it worked and he
would just have stays stacks of it did
he know right away he knew right away he
had no idea it was me oh really a decade
right so what we're filming that we're
filming the tv show that's patience yeah
we're filming the tv show and we're at
the and i'm not even there for the
payoff for most of it right no that's
crazy so i'm at i'm at the uh we're at a
bar and and then the shot girl is going
around she's like oh sign up for a
mailing list second nature i just
grabbed and started filling it in and
sal walks over and he looks down and he
sees his email he's like hey what's up
and it was like a kaiser sose moment oh
yeah you're right he was in a barber
shop in cortez
he starts putting it together together
and then he turns around and he goes oh
and he literally goes the craftmatic
that from years earlier
oh my god so it was like 10 and then he
just we i he
i laughed for about 20 minutes i
couldn't get me off the floor that bar
my best fantastic
but then did you want to know all the
reactions to all the other things well
no we got into like a conversation yeah
yeah
yeah
but he just he had so many questions
like how did you he must have been
stunned he must have been stunned that
you
just the patience yeah that you must
also like he must have been i'm
picturing sag because i know i'm a
little bit i love south like there must
have been like a mix of like admiration
and confusion like just that sound has
that that that's a big like there's a
that's a big part of the show especially
yeah murs like that too like if you pull
something off it's like bravo because it
says you're so torn you're like twisty
you're like all these sons they got me
and they're like that's my boys right
right but it's like i gotta go i gotta
respect it yeah uh
how you guys have known each other since
high school right
over 30 years at this point wow wow and
uh and it makes sense i mean you seem
like you all really love each other has
has there been anything oh on the show
where
it crossed a lot i mean have you crossed
lines on the show not really like
because we're friends at the end of the
day too like there'll be some times
where
well being able to say no like you could
like it's tv too right so you could tell
why somebody's saying no somebody's
saying no because they don't think it's
right for us to do or whatever like so
we might we keep each other in check
it's like yeah it's like it's like us
producing ourselves okay okay it's like
nah we shouldn't do that and the guys in
the back like no
like that'll be that's
oh yeah do that i'm like no no no who's
the who's the quickest to say no
um
i feel like you'd be the last to say
yeah me and q were probably the last
dish to say no omari's pretty bold too i
i think so at this point though like you
get used to it right it's kind of like
right always getting like every time you
shake hands you you get a little static
electricity shock you still shake hands
like oh here comes the shock yeah you
feel like you get a little that's true
into it and and i noticed that sometimes
like it must be
no just psychologically knowing that
it's being filmed yes it must embolden
you a little bit yeah you're alive
perfect example me and murray were just
in ralph's two nights ago we went to
pick up a sheet cake to bring over to a
friend's house
as a joke and uh
we were in the supermarket and for the
first time and i just started like
standing close to people and like i had
my you know my mess on something i just
started being like shopping like right
as they were putting stuff down just to
mess with them while we were waiting
yeah and murray was getting so nervous
and i turned him i said he goes i hate
being out with you in public i haven't
been out with you in public
and i said well it's because it's the
first time we've been in the supermarket
without a camera you can't just like oh
we're filming yeah that's true there's
no
there's like no security yeah so it was
really interesting he's like oh i can't
go out with you in public we're not
filming that's so funny and and he uh
that's right so you just do that
naturally yeah like this one was
shopping with the cheeses and when she
went up i was like nah like tell him
like that was the wrong way she like
looked at me like no not that one
she was like i just like for no reason i
bolded myself to help her with her
choices in the cheese well that's what
you do so well i you've taught me this
lesson which is um or you've really
solidified it which is if you say
something with confidence if you really
mean it you say like you mean it you can
kind of get away
with anything conviction you have total
conviction for sure yeah it's a real
strength i mean where do you think that
came from i mean was it your dad yeah my
my parents for sure
i got a little bit of that but i think
also
experience right yeah i'm also i was in
sales for a long time
that makes sense that's so funny my
brother wrote that down he said yeah one
we wondered if you had a background yes
i did sales was my sales my gym i moved
out here to chase the dream you know 305
to become a screenwriter i ended up
working at nordstrom's at the grove
platinum pacesetter i don't want to
brag but
it was just like i just fell into sales
and then
after like my i have an accounting
degree i got into consulting and then
after that uh i got into like
independent filmmaking on the side and i
was like i fell in love with it really
so i left the whole business part of it
i moved out here to to uh to choose the
stream yeah so no from all through to
five i lived out here for two years to
produce moves yeah to write and direct
oh no kidding
did you how did that go uh it was great
i wrote a couple things
and then i moved back home because my
grandmother passed away and my
grandmother my mother became widows
together so then my mother was truly
alone so i went home and i was like out
there i was like hugging her at the you
know the funeral i was like you know i
was like maybe i'll move back for a
minute like just saying it out loud and
she was like oh my god thank you and hug
me and cried i'm like okay sounds like
i'm coming back oh you floated yeah i
did yeah but it was good because i came
back and then the tenderloins yeah we
re com you know reconnected and oh
that's why
so so there had been a few years where
you guys were off doing earth yeah well
when i lived out here when i came home
we used to put up shows and i would be
home every couple months you know uh to
you know check in with the family
christmas time whatever we throw up like
we always self-produced our own improv
shows in manhattan so we would throw a
show up oh and then after i moved back
home we moved into sketch comedy on the
internet it got big that's like myspace
and yeah so we started doing that kind
of thing and that's how we transitioned
into and and and what was the hidden
camera element how did that get
introduced that we just decided to film
what made to making each other laugh oh
yeah wasn't it before a meeting with
true tv yeah so true tv was they were
like uh
murr was inside the development murray
was like a a permanent temp for a while
so he worked at a much different job
then he landed a gig at the production
company that we work with north south
and he became their uh he worked in
development
and he had heard whispers about like
people were looking for a new type of
you know prank show was like the thing
prank prank kind of deal and he was like
uh he's like hey let's think about what
our version of that would be and we were
just like we always get each other like
make each other laugh like let's just
film it so we literally took our our
iphones and just went and did it like i
stood in at time i went to times square
and there was a tyler perry presents
movie and i had to announce everybody
that i farted and i stood up and i just
owned it and it was like insanity and
like so we just did all these like
stupid things and a sizzle girl came
together really nice stand up in the
theater in the theater after previews i
stood up and packed theater
and people people started applauding for
me as i excuse myself because i had bad
mexican it was fantastic
[Music]
daily use of plus cbd sleep gummies get
you the rest you need so you can wake up
feeling focused and refreshed we've
talked about this before they're
formulated by a team of medical experts
and doctors they taste great they're
gummies they really do and they're made
with award-winning cbd combined with
melatonin magnolia bark lemon balm my
favorite balm all the things that you
need for a better sleep i love these
products oof they are
we both had one last night i had two
okay i had one and um they
really do
the trick
do they ever hey um we had a very
relaxing yes enjoyable
but i'm gonna stress relaxing or his
bachelorette contestants might say
relaxing relaxing
by the way woke up without any feeling
of like no
lethargy none it's they're the best yeah
the calm the calm gummies are great
sleep gummies are great and the ones
that combine have a little thc have 2.5
milligrams of thc which is what we had
last night who i dipped into i had five
milligrams wow not to brag this is a
great company visit
pluscbdoil.com and enter promo code long
for 40 off your order can you smell me
i'm raising my armpit in front of
christian you smell delicious yeah can
you smell me no i can't and i probably
because you just applied native
deodorant to your skin and you hadn't
even showered don't reveal that to
everybody i've been trying so many i've
tried a lot of other like natural
deodorants ever since i found out how
sensitive that area of your body really
is i've tried to switch over to a
natural brand and
i gotta say i've tried a lot of them
um i am even if they weren't paying us
to do this even if this weren't an ad
i'm a native
customer for life now i'm a convert too
yeah fully i i mean like the eucalyptus
mint is great i love that smell oh man
the coconut is one of my favorites
there's a lavender yes and you know what
it is it's subtle they're not like
perfumey pungent uh odors you know you
know it's exciting native now has new
seasonal scents i can't wait to try
these holiday scents oh cool light
candy cane they have
sugar cookies oh my god fresh mistletoe
imagine going to the gym and smelling
like a sugar cookie oh man how jealous
people will be i'm just gonna want to
eat guys armpits native deodorant is
formulated with ingredients you have
actually heard of like coconut oil shea
butter
their deodorant never uses aluminum
parabens sulfates any any of that bad
stuff but this is a big part but they
still keep you smelling amazingly fresh
all day long you never have to reapply
keep the sense of the season with you
and with natives limited time holiday
scented deodorants go to
nativedeodorant.com
and use code long to get 20 off your
first purchase at checkout that's
nativedeodorant.com code long for 20 off
nativedeodorant.com
code long
hello hello again
[Music]
but the only thing i don't do and why
our show works is i don't like making
people feel bad for comedy right your
show is making your friends feel bad so
like there'll be times in the beginning
when we're getting used to and getting
our feet like we'd be like um like we
did something like oh this is that's not
right this is something so we were
trying to calibrate it that's
interesting so the first seasons are a
little you know we got about through the
i would say the first half of the first
season we finally like oh okay that's it
this is it that's interesting you feel
weird and the people either confused or
like this guy's crazy like that's the
reactions we want we're not trying to
get people angry we're not there are
earlier episodes i'm thinking of where
it's borderline where it's like yeah not
that it's directly at somebody's expense
but it's dancing around with it yeah but
you guys do things like i'm imagining
now like just taking the cigarettes out
of people's mouths and like yeah there
are things that are are potentially
really like dangerous yes too and then i
mean we turn that and be like yeah we're
taking care of your health yeah i may be
a stranger but i'm worried about your
health yes so it kind of was like oh
that makes sense but no you're not
allowed to do that like i said like a
weird dynamic you play with the this is
what i love about us this is souther
because there is there's such a fine
line that separates
chaos and weirdness from like the normal
rules of society like the societal rules
that we all agree on and if you just
what you guys do so well is like you
just kind of [ __ ] with those rules a
little bit you're like twister in the
dial
just a little bit i'm picturing you with
the mashed potatoes that they're serving
the potatoes yeah i mean i made it
perfectly normal that a guy was walking
around throwing potatoes at the table
people were like yeah i'll take more
like literally the people were asking
for more like right right so sal was
like that doesn't happen in real life
like it happens if you make it normal so
that's really what we're just trying to
do we make the weird normal and i think
a lot of times the general public is
super surprised us i think from a social
like experiment yeah yeah they people
are so more on board to try stuff than
you think right because when they have
like permission to to like bend the norm
or be weird like it's like oh wow this
is this is fun oh let's try it yeah
yeah it's fun to play because most it
what you probably do for people is like
there is a mundane nature to going about
a day and like they have a story i mean
like there's nothing better than a good
story and like i'm picturing you in a
bikini washing that woman's car
phenomenal yeah this guy led me in his
truck to vacuum like what are you doing
for free for free but that was a big
thing i said no this is complimentary
service and the guy like is like oh yeah
i want my car wash but this guy's in a
bikini see i love
imagining people then retelling that
like how are they going to interpret
that and then go back to their friends
and be like their friends would be like
wait a bit what do you know like a full
like oh no two pieces i came out purple
made his eyes look nice they popped was
he a model no no no he's terrible
he should not be in any sort of that and
i guess it is about the personality mers
sometimes
gives off a different you know he has a
very different personality so when he's
doing something like i'm picturing
people leaving the parking lot having to
and he has to stall he has to like keep
them there
and that got a little dicey because
that's you know because people
[Music]
what is your weakness would you say in
terms of being gotten i don't like when
it goes like the worst moment for me on
the television show hands down was the
mets game i don't know this one when i
had the steel ball people noah
syndergaard who's uh their
one there
he used to so he was signing balls and
throwing him into he was in our pocket
he was our friend so he was signing
balls and throwing them into the crowd
but he just kept throwing into me and
there's a bunch of little kids oh it's
terrible and i had and i had a fanny
pack and i just kept collecting them and
telling people i could go on ebay no so
there's this woman standing there who
really wants when she is holding her
two-year-old child oh no so i say to her
i said oh you really you want a ball
give me a kid so she gives me her kid
i'm like no well let's get one for the
baby noah and he knows and he throws it
they made me keep calling him jeter too
which was really funny so like jeter
cheaters nothing like here at all right
so
not the same position but makes people
more upset cause like you don't even
know like his name is noah i'm like just
jeter
it's really funny so she he throws me a
ball and then i take i grab it and i get
the woman back her baby and i put the
ball in my fanny pack and she goes give
me that she goes wait give me the ball
and and i said oh you could get it on
ebay
and oh no she went nuclear oh like legit
the worst reaction hands out ask any of
us
embarrassing for her is there a moment
where you're like oh yeah yeah i was
like this is bad like yeah she's blurred
for like a reason
she wouldn't sign the thing she was she
was like flipping out and she was like
it was one of those moments where she
screamed at the top how dare you she's
screaming at me and the whole stadium
gets quiet because it's before the game
so the whole scene is quiet and looking
at us now and you know what you see i'm
in my ear yeah i'm in my ear it's dead
silent because nobody knows what to do i
said what do we do here boys quiet oh
nobody knows my god so then i said i was
like
you gotta say here's the ball i gave her
the ball he's like i was like uh okay
i'm i'm sorry i'm you know i'm sorry i'm
i'm i'm sorry you have to get on ebay
and i like walked away to get like the
final joke then the producers went up to
her and she like flipped out and she was
like what are you doing they they ended
up letting her meet noah take pictures
with him like to soften the whole thing
oh my god
it was hands down like it's the most
uncomfortable moment i think of the show
so even after that even after she got to
do a whole like song and dance with no
matter we didn't sign the thing yeah she
was that upset yeah
wow i'm so curious about that one but
then i was like she's got a kid i like
feel better and she has a kid yeah but
she also gave her a kid to a man that
she doesn't know to get a baseball right
i was like so i was like it's like i was
kind of weird so i didn't know i think
it just all happened so fast yeah so
that that moment of that was hands down
the most uncomfortable well that's a
good example of another thing i love
about the show is that it is so
revealing of human nature of human
behavior it's such a great study of yeah
you know i i'm you must encounter that
all the time and and it must make you
better at
walking in the world yeah you know
navigating navigating that the weirdness
of people and um wow i gotta see that i
can't believe that yeah you gotta make
sure you see that one that was was it
was that a new this news like probably
five season five oh my god um are there
ever times where you feel we gotta pull
the plug maybe on this this is getting
to like universal studios q's worst
moment hands down with universal studios
they do that tour and we kept making
them pull the emergency brakes oh god
that was crazy so that was that's where
i felt i felt bad i was like we're in
dangerous territory right now because
there's so many people so many people
there were cars ahead of you that were
like and he was he was he played it
perfectly he did what he had to do um i
love him for it it's one of the best one
of the best punches we ever did but for
for me that's probably that's probably
okay with the baseball for me like that
when he had to pull that final one
because they get people's time like he
said and yeah and then we made that we
made the guy say hey because this guy's
wasting so much of our time we're gonna
have to skip a part of it oh that's
right and then that just made the whole
people on vacation
paying money to do this waste of time so
for the listeners their uh q is on who's
on the show the friends of theirs uh
brian quinn is on a tram is on one of
those like universal tours now backlot
tour backlot tour and um
he keeps pulling the emergency stop like
break but and for not for like nonsense
reasons yeah i missed a picture could we
go back yeah there's like i missed what
you said could you say it
one of my favorite ones is we make a
pull it the guy comes over and says he
said i miss what you said could you say
it again he tells him what he said and
he goes away and then we make him pull
it right away and he comes back he goes
i just want to get off on the wrong foot
i'm sorry if i should be
so he apologizes for pulling it by
pulling it again
yeah that's right
brilliant uh and
is that stuff happening in the moment i
mean are you coming up with like in the
moment wow
we have some you know we have an idea we
have a framework that we go through but
a lot of it goes out the window yeah
when stuff starts happening i bet well
you got to like yeah that's where the
improv helps you know what's going on
it's like you just you dive in and yeah
we feed off each other somebody has an
idea you build you build your building
right
yeah like i'm picturing when they made
you sneezy
sneeze against a wall you do it once
it's funny then they're like do it
bigger bigger bigger and it just goes i
mean they love me as a result you're a
good fake sneezer i'm a great fake yeah
it's one of my one of my strengths yeah
not really good now in the world but
yeah i do i do a lot of uh the
receptionist gigs are always my they
can't they can't wait for me to go
you're a mate they love me as a
receptionist yes i think that i think
the hardest i probably made them laugh
was when i had to eat the i don't know
if you saw where they they replaced the
chair with a uh a workout ball you know
one of those people yesterday yes i saw
that yeah
yeah and sal's turn he had had a hand a
turkey sandwich and he threw it out in
the garbage and they said joe if you
could orchestrate to fall off the ball
knock down the knock down the garbage
can and eat the sandwich uh you win and
i and i didn't just kept saying yeah as
i was eating and you heard them they
were around the corner of like an office
around the other side the woman heard
them laughing throughout i was literally
going guys be quiet
what is the name that you remember uh
having a heart and a hardest time not
laughing at when when you're having to
read out names oh dr shrimp puerto rico
what is dr shrimp puerto rico is a rough
one yeah that's one of my favorite names
we've ever came up with dr puerto rico
it's great yeah yeah mother coconuts is
a fun one too that we hear a lot but
yeah the hardest one was uh this fat
[ __ ] oh yeah i remember
that one this about this bad [ __ ]
and you have to do it without laughing
and is there um how long can you take
before you say it like cause i noticed
that you you could take it you could
take a minute
but i found the longer you take the
harder oh really oh really harder again
because you're thinking about
anticipation that's exactly right um
and what are your
i i imagine your family is all very
close
yeah what do you what do your siblings
think of what you do are they ever
afraid that they're gonna be roped into
the uh now they've gotten in in a little
bit you know my daughter's been roped in
a little bit it sounds dad they're
always bringing that yeah yeah we get
him all the time he's not speed dial i
love it he calls us sometimes he's like
i got an idea
but he's the best he's awesome who were
your influences as a kid like who did
you watch growing up no brooks yeah yeah
mel brooks loved uh the zucker brothers
you know yeah airplane those movies i
loved uh
you know i i always loved physical
comedy uh yeah i was one of my biggest
cow burnett yes hands down cow brunette
show laughing uh was huge for me like
all that old school comedy stuff but
then like i like i enjoyed stand up too
richard jenny was my friend my father
him tim allen we used to watch all that
you watched with your dad and my dad
yeah that's cool so that sort of stuff i
loved but i was always physical comedy
always movie i'm more of them laurel and
hardy did you get it yes yeah i got into
um
yeah i really liked i love lucy you know
old school stuff like that but for for
the most part it was like the muppet
show oh yeah it was huge for me who was
your mother who was your father oh yeah
of course i love fozzie yeah he's my jam
and my son loves muppet babies and
fozzies oh really that's pretty cool
he's six yeah my son's four my
daughter's sick oh all right
uh that must be so cool to get to
introduce so cool you're kids
yeah yeah i love that and then my my
daughter is like a little bit of uh
starlet she loves to sing and loves that
loves the attention but then she
realizes and gets really nervous and
wants to hide so that's really cool but
i had really cool experience when we
played msg
when we played radio city i just was the
first time i brought my daughter and i
have a great picture at the end i
brought her out we just had had her and
i brought her out at the end and and i
just have a picture they grabbed the
picture of me with my fist off like
presenting her to the world oh that's my
symbol moment i was like
so that was really cool and then when we
played when we played madison square
garden i got to do the same thing with
my son oh that's i have a great photo
with my kids on that it's just like
great memories well she's been on the
show too yeah she's been on the show
yeah she's been down there and she's
good on the show she's great she's like
really she's great she's great yeah um i
remember one where like you had to have
uh you had to be like terrible parents
that's is that hard it was a parenting
group yeah and it was my punishment they
said they're like we got your child
actor and my daughter walks through the
door and i had to like i had to they
re-rewrote all my questions what i had
to answer
one of the questions was they made me
say that he's like oh how do you get
discipline tips for your children they
made me say i watch uh the dog whisperer
would say oh yeah
and i had to take out a bag of cheerios
and treated like treats and i had to
make a roll over and she was phenomenal
she's just so fun and game but she
didn't know what's going on she's like
oh daddy's saying roll over oh yeah oh
she did it so naturally it's like she
she played it so well that like it
really reinforced how real the other
thing was because we spent a lot of time
we play a lot and stuff she's bad though
i bet you must be that must have been
you must be a
fun dad yeah it's fun it's it's fun
because
like the the with the world shutting
down we travel so much and everything
yeah and it worked so much i really
didn't have you know if we're going to
be honest and really have a good
relationship with my kids at all like
they didn't really know me that much
yeah literally two weeks before the
pandemic i was came home and my daughter
was really excited and we had a good day
and she goes daddy i love when you come
to visit and i was like i just ripped my
heart i was like i'm doing something
wrong here right and then fast forward
i'm just home with them and i got to
build this great relationship with them
so now going back now it's like okay now
i'm doing a nice really foundation yeah
there's a good foundation so well thank
god for the pendant i mean that's really
why i started it oh check that out
what were the limitations then in terms
of doing the show during the pandemic
like what what were the difficulties
well a lot of the show is actually set
up for success with social distance and
just worked into it we present
presentations focus groups things of
that nature like we were able just to
lean into that really what went away was
walking into a supermarket tapping
somebody on the shoulder or being in the
park like that kind of just a random
stuff yeah we just figured out a
different way to do it and how do we
make like
a fake coffee shop or how do we make a
fake like just make these make these
scenarios with these people that we've
brought in yeah so and it was good it
helped us think of new ways to play and
when you were selling things were you
ever when you were you mentioned being a
salesman which is what you do so well on
the show you sell these weird even with
the potatoes it's like
oh i'm just you're making people laugh
like you've you're flipping the script
um
was there ever a moment where you felt
like i could do this for my life were
you happy doing that or or were you
always thinking about i love comedy i
love sales and comedy was always kind of
like the side yeah it's like a hobby
yeah but then it presented when it
presented itself it's funny because
everybody else was actually able to keep
their job oh yeah i was the first one i
had to quit oh that's funny so i was all
in from the beginning so we filmed the
pilot on my two-week vacation when i was
working with this baby store giggle and
i was a personal shopper and their
training program manager so i go to my
ceo's office and i'm like hey i need i'm
gonna take my two week vacation we're
filming this pilot for jokers so we
don't film the pilot and then they pick
it up
they say okay you need six months and i
go and i'm like hey i'm gonna take a six
month hiatus just like so you're
quitting and i'm like no no no i'll be
back and she's like well no i hope you
don't have to come yeah yeah and she
said she said but if you do there'll be
a place here for you but it won't be
this job uh-huh she's like i had to
replace you and i was like okay so then
it just so i you were all in wow but
which is good because i really i always
wanted to direct always you know that's
my i will be a director like that's what
i want to do so this is kind of like a
little detour
a little
detour um but like that's what i want to
do so i got fell into the production
part of it really took to the production
part show running like learning part of
it really when they do the behind the
scenes yeah like you're yeah i very much
became the part of that which i really
it interested me and yeah it also helped
the show because it had our voice in it
totally you know so it was really good
oh that's great what kind of stuff do
you want to direct do you have something
in mind yeah that's your first yeah yeah
i do i have kind of i just actually we
talked about when i moved out here i had
written a short film 13 years ago and i
just filmed it in may oh no which is
awesome i just finished it it was great
oh that's great and
it's it that's back in yeah in upstate
new york yeah i did two overnight and
overnight shoot of uh i think it's an
eight-minute short it's great i love it
it came really good oh good i'm really
happy with it how do people see it um
it's not out yet okay yeah so well i'm
actually having meetings about that with
other people right now which is cool so
it's fun like to do it i really just did
it because it was a calling card because
when i started talking to people about
want to direct and having an out there
like okay what do you have yeah and i
only i didn't have something i i've had
this great script i was sitting on i
just needed time to do it and i found
the time and i was like oh great so
that's the other thing you guys are all
such i said this to sell he wouldn't
accept the compliment but like you're
such good actors you i mean you have to
be well i i think you are i mean i
really do think you are that you have no
you you're the good actor in the room i
don't think so i mean like you have to
be because all it is is being present to
a scenario to a situation and and
committing to something i mean you of
all are so
committed the commitment level is our
problem yeah the memorization and being
comfortable in that skin is a little
different well it's just that's just
mechanics but i guess
what you guys do is like you have to
convince if anything it's harder you
have to like convince people that you
are existing in the world that's true
same is ridiculous because we're in the
real world i never thought of it that
way dr shrimp puerto rico like you have
to like that first thing
you have to convince people that you
think stacked your friend puerto rico
might be in a room
that's true that's very challenging i
could never do that we should win in
oscar i see what you're saying yes yes
uh has it made you more bold in life
yeah yeah well i've always been pretty
bold but but like now it's just it's
just crazy it's funny because like with
some stuff
like with the fame is kind of annoying
because like you can't really do what
you want to do it anymore right so like
i used to always do this bit with sal
whenever we walked into a store like
shopping i'd yell yeah what's the
discount what's the action like i would
come in right away talk who's the
manager what am i talking i need twenty
percent off i'm gonna do some damage in
here like i would do that any story or
anywhere anywhere because i know rita
i've been working retail forever it's
all bs everybody can mark down whatever
the hell they want there's a code for
something like don't don't tell me
there's not so i would just go into
every store and
ten times out of ten i would get a
discount right all right so
now when i do it it's like it's i now i
call it a celebrity discount sal and
he's like dude you can't ask for a
celebrity
like joke around but like that was some
of my favorite jokes to do because
people kind of expect it for you or you
get away with more because i know you're
in the eye but it was fun for me when i
wasn't i know exactly isn't that kind of
disappointing when you get away with
i've had that because i used to love
this was also why i love the show i
loved messing with i loved attempting to
do what you guys do so well like you
guys take it to elevate it to an art
form i think but like i've always loved
doing that like messing with the
societal norms or whatever but like uh i
remembered that moment of where i
couldn't really do that anymore where it
wasn't as easy to do it right anyway
where people would and i i remember the
feeling of somebody laughing
uh
it's right you're like oh man no i
wanted to be some element of like i
shouldn't be doing this yeah yeah
farting in church yeah that's exactly
right yeah the church laugh is that
that's
the best i want us to live bits in
church were always so fun because it was
like yeah you're not supposed to do that
the stakes are really high yeah well i
thought the guys got me at my uh
sorry about my grandmother's uh my
grandmother's funeral we were all pretty
close to my grandma too and i'm given
the eulogy uh-huh and somebody's cell
phone goes off during the yoga is dead
quiet but it's i'm not kidding it's the
theme to halloween no
so immediately i lock eyes with sal
murray in the back and i'm like look at
them and i'm talking that's why you were
doing the show and no oh oh no this was
an accident
and the person wouldn't answer their
phone and sal it just starts like this
so i thought it was them and i'm like
these guys there's nothing sacred right
so then after did you address it during
the year no i just let it happen because
i at the moment it was for me it was
like oh these guys definitely did it but
i was like if it wasn't them it's really
going to embarrass somebody just let it
go yeah so after i go up to them and
selma they were like it wasn't us we
swear we like we thought you set it up
to be a joke and i was like i didn't i
was like how great is that
fast forward to like season six we do
the punishment with sal's at a poetry
reading and his phone keeps going off
singing whose phone is ringing mine mine
and he can't answer it that's directly
influenced from our life oh you know
what i mean so like oh that poetry
reading was amazing
that we couldn't say he couldn't answer
it all those people hated him hated him
and like that's got to be hard for all
of you guys because you're all set you
all seem like really good people and
like you don't want to hurt people but
like sal had to [ __ ] on other people's
poems uh-huh that was um because sal in
particular is like seems like such a
sensitive guy
but you don't even realize like what you
think people hold sacred like one of
sal's biggest ones that we couldn't
believe it went that way was when he had
to keep yelling bingo in a bingo ball
with all these blue hairs in connecticut
and
he was dude they were out for blood and
we're like
they were like
one person told me they were gonna stab
him like it was insanity it was absolute
mayhem and sal was like dude i'm gonna
get shipped out here it was craziness a
thousand bluegrass playing bingo
sal's life is on the line
that's right that was
yeah you um
yeah it must be surprising when you
realize like the stakes for other people
yeah because did you use like it's a
bingo game but like
this is bingo this is sunday big brother
sunday bingo get out yeah um oh man
that's really funny uh i i i want to get
back to um
the adopt-o-shop uh charities that you
work with how many right because i know
so you say you have nine i have nine
right now nine right now and what's the
most you've ever had at one time ten
yeah we just lost bella cheesecake oh
hey we have another cheesecake for a hot
minute she stopped by so i have uh
cannoli biscotti oh yeah
yeah yeah cannoli biscotti tartufo
spomoni napoleon panna cotta
ganache
uh strufela those are my none and we had
bella cheesecake we actually threw this
my aunt she was on her way out my aunt
just needed somebody she couldn't take
care of her anymore so we had her for
about a week uh and we just all dogs all
dogs yeah one boy napoleon's the only
boy uh-huh it's kind of hard when you
have but a pack mentality is awesome
like they just come in and they all just
follow each other but scotty's the mama
bear yeah what is that a big one uh no
biscotti my biggest one is stroophyla
she's 50 pounds but the rest are all
like small little white doggy kind of
deals an ex-girlfriend um had a friend
of the show uh maggie q had seven uh
dogs i remember when we were together
and and the um
the one they were all big all big big
rescues and uh the one that like ruled
like ran the ruse the the alpha was mr p
who was this tiny little chihuahua it
was the funniest crazy thing to see the
dynamic yeah this thing would just like
kind of go around yeah
it's just so weird the way dogs that
they're they're just nature and
everything it's just insane when you
introduce a new one it's it's crazy when
you were a kid were you like we had one
dog i had one dog for 17 years
i got we got her when i was one we had
to put her down when i was 17. oh that's
huge especially little schnauzer who ran
the roost
my parents just opened the door in the
morning she would leave she'd come back
at night to get fed like we didn't know
what she did around the world
fantastic yeah he was like feral by day
it was crazy yeah my father one day was
driving home and on harbor road where i
lived there was a pothole and he looked
and the dog was sleeping in the puddle
she was like taking a nap and i was like
oh so you have to go get a big rock and
put like a rocket
what did your dad do oh my dad was
insurance salesman uh okay he was a vice
president of insurance company wow so
it's in your blood yeah for sure yeah
for sure yeah yeah this must go without
saying but like he i bet he'd be really
yeah thrilled to see yeah yeah i think i
think yeah i think he'd be proud of the
guy i am it's funny because i only had
until i was 18. yeah so i've had him you
know less than half my life yeah just
the impact they make so that's why i
learned about you know
the time you have yeah the you know
parenting and all that stuff that really
influences the way i think about it like
i always always have a joke with the guy
i'm like yeah i'm on my way out guys
like we always make that joke i'm not
afraid of it like it's like that's the
way it is just you know legacy being the
best person you could be and stuff like
that well so in that sense i must give
you a healthy outlet for sure
yeah i do have a healthy outlook i have
well it's funny because sal always loves
me because you either have it completely
right or completely wrong i don't know
which it is like you should not be this
comfortable with it yeah yeah yeah right
he said you know but i like you know we
always joke about you know my parents
and and death and stuff and it doesn't
matter like my kids know about death
might you know really yeah because my
you know when my dogs die like
i've had 12 dogs over the course well
that's how i was introduced to because i
had so many animals growing up so i had
to kind of understand i had to have some
understanding of it but but how do you
how do you explain that to a kid like
how do you well i you just talk openly
right you know my my son remo calls we
have pictures of my mom up at the house
whatever he's like he calls her the dead
grandma
he's like oh yeah when i tell a story
and he's like was that grandma a dead
grandma like do we live you know but you
know what would she laugh at that i mean
like hundred percent yeah like we should
make jokes about my dad with her you
know yeah so it was always it was it was
never you know taboo thing was always
you know laughter's healing in my family
kind of deal life could be a dream
sweetheart
[Music]
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war is ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb but
then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wandery
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis
and the survivors fight to stay alive
it's a fascinating story you probably
know the story of the uss indianapolis
from the famous scene in jaws that
robert shaw recounts
it is harrowing to say the least sailors
who survived the attack were stranded in
the open ocean for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survived the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listen to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wondering
plus in the wondery app hey life assured
listeners business wars is a podcast
from wondering that brings you the full
stories behind some of the biggest
business battles in history in their new
season you'll hear about the fight
between espn vs fox sports to dominate
the sports television industry espn is
the american cable network that plays
the trail for around the clock sports
coverage athletes even change the way
they play just to get on sportscenter's
nightly highlight reels but right around
the corner rupert murdoch's fox sports
channel started gaining on espn in the
us the sports tv business is worth more
than 12 billion dollars the question is
who will come out on top fox sports or
espn listen to business wars espn versus
fox sports on apple podcast amazon music
or you can listen one week early and add
free by joining wondering plus in the
wondery app
hello hello
we'll meet again
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say your go-to
emoji i don't really use emojis never no
hardly use emojis really yeah i have a
hatred for emojis oh wow okay
yeah i'm sorry wow it's weird that you
brought this trick
people oh yeah wow
you know what you know what's funny like
i'll use them ironically and one i do
use a lot is the woman that's like oh
yeah okay i don't know that one ironic
use still counts
i guess i use it but it's few and far
between okay uh if you could be a
professional athlete what sport would
you play look at me nothing well
if you had to if someone if my back was
a couple of deranged billionaires like
do it yeah i'm a pretty i'm pretty bad
ass bowler oh okay i would bowl okay
cool what sport would you consider the
sport i think so yeah i think it is a
sport yeah yeah uh what is your do you
have like a high score 288 oh josh
you're really good i was on the high
school bowling league it's been a while
like i don't really roll 288's anymore
but that was my highest are you a
germaphobe but i'll do it
no so
my thing was always the holes yeah yeah
you gotta you gotta have your own ball
though yes that's true that's it that's
what the professionals do oh that's true
yeah have you been uh bowling since yeah
we just went pretty recently oh really
yeah my niece's nephew we took my uh my
daughter it was fun
do you hang out with the guys off the
show sal kind of mentioned that you
occasionally but like for the most you
guys work together some time yeah when
we're on the road we do like it's like
when it's like you want to go shopping
your friends are there you want to go to
a movie you're friends yeah yeah but
when you're home like you're trying to
see your either your other friends right
you know what i mean it's like it's
funny because they're non-tv you're not
tv friends but during the summer like we
go to each other's maybe you know for a
barbecue like once each house over the
summer you know so like four or five
times did murray's lawn grow back in
yeah barely yeah like literally just now
his curb is still pink like this part of
his curve that's just like still pink
like there's no way it's coming out i i
love how proud he is he is of his like
property yeah and i love that it plays
on his vanity calls it proper yeah i'm
like your yard burn like he's like it's
a property i like your yard dude pretty
big yeah it is pretty big um
uh that's really funny who if you could
oh and you guys are speaking of uh tour
you're going on tour this fall yeah
right let's announce it yeah great uh in
september you started we're starting to
start in uh november november 17th our
first one yeah god i'd like to see that
because i'm curious i'm curious how you
incorporate a live
this show into a live yeah it's it's
more like the hanging out part of it
where we tell stories about each other's
lives but there's also that's great a
lot of video elements it's multimedia
it's got it's real fun okay november uh
all over the country of the year we just
launched them so we're just we just
ruined at least 40 dates i think oh
great starting in november if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life i know by the way sal does a great
uh snack uh taste buds his podcast is so
great it's so funny uh that's based on
that's based on so many i mean sound
i've also had so many conversations
about that soccer debate snacks foods
like we we had a tour bus once we got
into it about uh what was the best uh
yeah it was the best um el fudge uh
versus uh you know uh a chips ahoy chips
yeah but for me uh my favorite snack
food i would probably have to go with
like a hostess cupcake oh really yeah no
kidding yeah of course if we're talking
like if we're talking like a snack food
from the yeah but if it's not it's a
cannoli if it's a it's a italian pastry
it's a cannoli oh it's going to say
because you are like a real pastry guy
that's my deal what is there a canola
you want to promote is there a place
about staten island is it would it be
place down by me st rocco's bakery
really phenomenal yeah okay i go there
every sunday morning a particular flavor
of cannoli uh right just straight up
standard issue yeah they make a great
they make a great lobster tail too if
you're into it okay
and and how close is that to a
cheesecake is that my brother's been
trying to get me to he's been trying to
turn me off did you just ask me how
close a cannoli is to it well i mean in
terms of because i have a problem with
the cheese element
oh i got to the ricotta element yeah
that sounds like that sounds like a
banana that's like movie you and i
should make an action
[Laughter]
movies what is your favorite movie
sequel of all time the sequel yeah oh
that's a good one uh
well i mean godfather two definitely
rises because it's fantastic i feel like
that's that is the answer everybody yeah
oh you know what i really enjoyed john
wick too oh really yeah okay i gotta see
it i like john wick i can't believe i've
never seen john wayne the john wick
movies are fun they're filming right
yeah what's the movie you really want to
introduce uh your son and your daughter
too well we just started dabbling into
some of the star wars stuff she's a
little young which is fun but i can't
wait till they get into some of the
marvel stuff i love all them oh you do
but
my favorite one for them to watch which
i really think they'll like because they
both are like adventurous too i goonies
is the one for me that yeah i want to
watch
it's either that or galaxy quest oh yeah
yeah oh
oh i loved galaxy questions you know i i
don't know if i shouldn't say this but
they're doing a serie a galaxy quest
like limited series shut up yes simon
pegg is writing it
yeah yeah simon just said he texted me
and said what's your character i was
like i wonder i hope i'm in it so and he
said what's your character's last name i
was like oh good phenomenal i'm excited
i'm so excited about that and the
goonies i've been thinking about a lot
lately because uh sadly richard donner
died um uh superman i i need to rewatch
that his superman oh yeah such a great
director yeah yeah um yeah i mean
goonies for me it was like because i was
always that adventure like kind of
totally did too so that was that it was
just spoke to my soul yeah i can't wait
for uh for my kids to watch yeah i bet
oh that'll be so fun it makes me want to
have kids
you know you borrow mine okay good all
right i'll let you know when we're gonna
watch if you come on by okay okay
perfect who's this guy he just wants to
have the experience my friend justin
yeah yeah don't worry you're drinking
water
[Laughter]
he keeps staring at me um what's your
what is your go-to karaoke song um i'm
i'm known for my hype man skills oh yeah
so i'll be like flavor flavor yeah yeah
i'm like i'm uh joining pain oh pop out
okay yeah come on come on yeah here we
go here we go like that's me that's
that's my guy that's where i live okay
um who was your first celebrity crush
that you remember like the the one that
made it carpenter oh yeah i would
probably say yeah from buffy uh yeah she
was up there for me uh but i didn't
watch buffy uh yeah
she was on angel too but i i i just
remember loving her but alyssa milano
for sure come from staten island you
know for sure yeah it's definitely one
of my celebrity crushes yo she was great
uh do you have any tattoos i do not oh
that sounds story is amazing yeah
[ __ ] jason's great that's great that
was brilliant um
uh if you had to get one what would it
be where i'd probably get my if i had to
i'd probably get my children's initials
inside of a cannoli
i feel like it's everything that and
like there's a poor prince
that's great uh what is your favorite
fruit my favorite fruits in apricot oh
okay that was a quick answer yeah i feel
like it's underused yeah yeah you know
what i why though because there was an
apricot in my room okay a hotel and i
had it this morning it was delicious i
mean a ripe plum is also good i'm
thinking
my grandfather orchard out here he had
no kidding property and had a huge he
had a huge like garden he grew
everything
that's property right yeah that's not a
property yeah yeah like uh he had like
everything from prickly pears to like
watermelon and strawberry like he grew
everything that's amazing your
grandfather my grandfather yeah oh why
in l.a yeah he lived uh yeah he lived in
the valley oh that's so cool
what happened to the farm they sold
unfortunately they still didn't move
back to new york before anybody would
have been able to buy it like i would
have isn't that i drove by it not too
long ago i drove by like i was out here
about six months ago for some meetings
or something and i was in the va i was
like you know what i'm gonna drive by so
i texted my sister and she knew the
address and i drove by and it kind of
the house was there oh really i could
see it and i kind of like they changed
where the front door was and stuff so i
could kind of like still get a feel
isn't that funny do you believe in
ghosts uh yeah ish
i believe in i believe in uh i don't
think people just go away yeah you know
but i just heard this thing from a
stand-up that was really funny is like
you never hear about modern ghosts it's
like always somebody from the 1700s
yeah so that ghost is wearing a charles
barkley jersey i i don't know he's like
like he's like a late 90s ghost you know
he's got nike's on yeah i i i after like
i feel like you don't want to forget
people and i think you make connections
a lot too yeah but there have been some
things in my life that i was like oh
that's too weird with people who have
passed yeah my father especially like
after some stuff i was like oh that's a
little weird that's been coming up a lot
on the show things in nature i've felt
uh when michael's my grandma died
recently and um we were really close uh
italian she was uh jody finale uh she
was the best but she she was on the show
she was oh some friend of the show yeah
so people feel like you know it's nice
they they're like kind of feel like you
know and they did she was really great
but um
she uh yeah i keep feet seeing her there
are moments
things you mentioned yeah you'll you'll
do i don't know if it's because you're
you're putting it out there i don't know
or maybe you're putting it out there and
you're open to it yeah yeah that could
be part of it but you've definitely felt
things 100 yeah i was one of the
weirdest experience of my life i'm
driving in philadelphia i worked in
philly after my dad had passed away and
i was thinking about him and my window
was open for some reason i was thinking
about giving him a hug and for some
reason i focused on an acorn in a
parking lot on in a tree
for no reason at all the acorn i'm
driving like 20 miles an hour through
like a parking lot the acorn falls out
of the tree bounces and comes in my open
window and i catch it like this like
when you hug somebody i still have the
acorn i was like that is you can't
explain that joe just put his cheek to
it yeah like when you know
he must have been young yeah yeah he
died he was 56 jesus yeah
wow and was it sudden was it that uh
yeah he they gave him he had pancreatic
cancer they gave him the game six months
he gave him three months he got six out
of it um but like in my dad fashion like
as soon as he found out he had it yeah
he's like we're going to vegas he took
the whole family to vegas no maybe get a
fake id so you could play blackjack with
me yeah yeah like fantastic like one of
the best trips ever oh my gosh i was
like such a great like you know memory
card yeah yeah and then he was it he was
at home too so it was good like they
didn't want to he talked to the doctor
and they're like this you know this is
95. yeah you know they're nowhere near
with cancer yeah they were and he was
like they're like well do they came over
on easy he looked at me said look i'm
looking for quality not quantity wow
he's like what are we talking about here
and they're like you know maybe you get
a year it's like a year sick or you're
three months healthy yeah and then just
he's like i'm doing it that way really
and he had started he had such peace
with it that he made everybody
comfortable about it really he was like
at home and he was just like he was just
great the way he handled it was just
like i think that's part of it that
embodies me about like yeah the no fear
of it grace in death is like what a gift
yeah to to yeah and if you were there
with him there all the way to the end it
was just like you know you're on that
journey with them
man
to be comforted by the person who is was
insane like people would come crying
into his room and i'm like he's the one
dying
wow
you know
so oh my god which is crazy i would
aspire to be i mean that's what you
aspire to be like right and the other
side of it was my mom so my dad had the
strong thing and my mom was always like
my mom was such a firecracker and she
was like i don't want to get old i never
wanted to get all she's like she always
put that out there in the university i
don't want to get old i want to be
decrepit she was always like she was
like a fun 67 68 or whatever she wasn't
she was just always like loud fun
working independent like that kind of
thing you know then yeah and then you
know she literally like went in her
sleep like one night and it was like
gone yeah like we got the phone call and
we went to the hospital and she was gone
and i was like that's it true drop the
mic um
where were we what a great digression uh
who would you want to play you in your
biopic joe you yeah yeah you're the only
choice
i don't know if i have the balls my
balls are weighted i mean you know what
i get all the time that kind of uh steve
carell looks like me
yeah yeah the steve girl oh for sure
uh i bet he didn't really enjoy playing
yeah he watched the show we found out on
twitter on twitter we found out i would
go and obama and they uh the
fan comes in from the street and um you
know i'm shopping and they say okay take
a picture i said yeah i took a picture
with them and i'm buying a bunch of food
because my wife's in the car and
pregnant she was hungry on the way back
so i'm like okay i buy a bunch of food
and the woman at the checkout as i check
out she's like i just wanted to say and
uh you know i'm a huge fan to me and i
was like oh thank you she's like yeah i
loved evan almighty and the office and i
was like
does this woman think i'm there so i was
like and i don't sound like i'm sorry i
smile yeah yeah if you didn't get a
quick picture and then she everybody
comes out i get behind me i take a
picture with the whole group and then i
post it on twitter and i'm like hey
thanks for the free sandwich they
thought i was you and i tag a minute and
he said no problem thanks for the laughs
oh that's awesome and the company
tweets hey uh we'll give you a black
card mr corel uh you could uh next lunch
is on us whatever you want and i tweeted
back what are you talking about where's
my black card
so he got like free for life
well it's a pretentious sandwich
well now you don't get anything that's i
thought you mentioned favorite muppet
which is one of our questions is fozzie
um what's your favorite muppet movie
what's the one that you want to
introduce to your kids oh the caper
right the crown man sure oh charles
grodin what a lost sure yeah he was so
good in that he's in one of my favorite
movies ever uh um with uh with de niro
midnight and runs phenomenal i just
rewatched it not too long ago uh totally
holds up he's so fun to watch i've been
watching him on uh old talk shows like
him on letterman and yeah where he's
just playing like that curmudgeonly uh
persona he's talking about i mean
commitment yeah sure that's joe gatto
level um
um what is your go-to pizza topping um
for me a black olive i like a good black
really yeah i'll do a baked olive uh and
do you have a pizza place in new york
that you love i have uh well new york
new york pizza is fantastic yeah i just
love new york pizza overall i mean but
by by me there's a place called uh
phil's okay which makes a drunken
sicilian it's called it's a sicilian
pizza with uh paneer
vodka sauce oh wait instead yeah which
is phenomenal where is that
it's in phil it's phil's in uh glenn
cove new york glenn cove okay cool um
dogs are cats you prefer i mean what are
we doing here
on there i will put it out here though
you know this and this is something that
steer into my heart yeah let's talk
about it okay i don't not like cats okay
all right i don't want to be that you
know i'm not a person dog or cat guy
okay because it's a stigma that needs to
go away
i'm just promoting this
all right i don't want you to be part of
the problem i'm looking to be part of
solution mr long okay what other animals
let's throw in a chinchilla oh man don't
get me started okay they're basically
they're cute they're cute rats like
nobody wants you like nutrients yeah
it's like a guinea pig yeah squeeze it
down it's a rat that's got a good
haircut i'm not into it but for me a
parakeet or any of the flight birds i'm
a fan of i love a parrot i had an
african grey for a little bit oh really
yeah what what what other non-uh dog
another non-dogs uh you know i i could
rescue a lot of things you could you
could be surprised when you dressed yeah
out there yeah yeah i do uh i never
gotten a fish no reptiles and reptiles
were not that i don't like them but it's
not i'm more of a cuddly yeah kind of
guy yeah you know like a good cuddle
well that's your bed seems so like yeah
furry and it's crazy what are the three
that don't sleep on there the old ones
oh yeah
and ganache they they're they're on the
floor well panda hannah can't see so
she's gonna know why so uh panda can't
see and kata's got no eyes kata's got no
eyes silence but phenomenal life she
lives she loves belly rubs yeah but they
just walk off the bed so they can't
laughing at them
again you probably will object to this
but beatles are the rolling stones i
don't really know music
what yeah i'm not really i don't really
know much music so um the beatles the
rolling stones i don't think i can name
a rolling stone song you're kidding uh a
single song i don't think i can to shame
you but no it's what about a beatles
song beatle song yeah right the el
submarine in this thing yes
you know i just got i just got into uh
johnny cash a little bit oh yeah um by
accident because i was on a playlist i
was realized but i do i do i probably
had to pick one say the beatles okay
yeah i probably know more beatles songs
ones yeah there you go
uh i'm more of a pop music a guy or an
oldies like do what beef 1950s oh okay
that's what i listened to growing up
with my parents and stuff oh yeah yeah
that's funny me too that's what started
me in like more uh you're like a big
music guy i love music but it was stand
by me it was the soundtrack for stand by
me i remember getting and like that kind
of opened up everything um yeah uh
science do you like do you watch tv are
you
seinfeld or friends seinfeld yeah yeah
it's funny right yeah sal answered it
the same way um i i imagine sal and i
probably have the most it's so funny
because sal and i really get into it
when it comes to music because sal knows
like every music but he knows like the
obscure ones too and it gets so annoying
he'll be like he shames all the time me
and murray and he'll be like how could
you not because how do you not know
funky coco in the pop-pop like like i'm
like nobody knows funky go go in the
pop-up he's like kidding me he's like
they sang wandango i'm like what are you
talking about no one knows the words
that are coming out of your mouth that's
so he goes i think it's indignant like
he's very very uppity with it i bet yeah
yeah
yeah
uh ketchup or mustard do you prefer uh
ketchup uh and well i put both on i put
both on a veggie hot dog though you do i
throw a relish in a sauerkraut on there
too i love the fixins what's a good uh
non-meat um hot dog hamburger oh beyond
the beyond brand i love that yeah yeah
beyond sausages for a fake sauce and
pepper so good i know the beyond is
really good and yeah of course we keep
talking about being in la what's um
what's a great vegetarian vegan place in
l.a uh crossroads the restaurant is
phenomenal yeah but i love that uh
purevita is phenomenal yeah they make a
great like i you know i grew up on
italian food and i was like wow this is
phenomenal oh that's good to know um and
joe what are two adjectives you would
like people to use to describe you after
you've gone we're talking talking about
like you're eulogy like little j remo is
given i would say uh we i would say kind
and brave yeah those are we have a
mantra in the gatto house be brave be
kind be a gatto and we say it every day
before the kids go to school and that's
no kidding that we try to well you
embody that i i think both of those
virtues you are a true it had been so
fun to watch on that show and i i just
love i love it so much i'm i'm so
appreciative of it that's great well
you've given me years of i owe you years
of entertainment no no you guys are
phenomenal you're uh yeah it's been such
a joy so thank you and thank all the
thank marin and q i got to have them on
the show yeah i'm sure they'll hit you
up next i mean you start with sal you
know so now you're just working down the
ladder
at the end we're going to ask you you're
going to rate us and i'll say oh yeah
okay all right compared to sal how did i
do it because that was a good one i
don't know it was a good one this was
great it was it's so fun i just it again
like i you guys are so easy to talk to
but it um and i'm glad because i i i
could have gone into this like knowing
you or thinking i know you the way i do
and then
i don't know you're like uptight and
like what a really big huge rolling
stones fan
yeah all and then you come to find out
it was all just for the show
but uh no you guys are are great i'm
really murray
take off your wig
um no i i really appreciate it uh all
the laughs thanks so much for having me
thanks joe
so so that just happened that just
happened
yeah that just happened
kind of like that he's got a great i
love don't you love it's
i love it phenomenal well she says
phenomenal oh my god it's you got to try
the trees the panda cotta it's
phenomenal these cannolis are the most
phenomenal they're the most you got to
get them in your mouth they're
phenomenal you know who would um he's
got like a vince and i was thinking that
because vince is the only other person
who uses that word yes so freely it's
phenomenal phenomenal he does that's one
of my favorite things he does when he
eats a lot in wedding crashes he's such
a funny eater that wedding montage of
wedding crashers i think brilliant might
be the best movie
montage comedy movie montage of all time
you don't have to think the wedding
montage in wedding crush is the best
movie montage what did you say yes i
mean what's better than that oh no to
and to a song that i previously had
always been annoyed by uh yeah you
should get up and generally shout
that's annoying i don't like being told
what to do in a song you know like i i'm
not gonna you don't like the ymca
i kind of like ymca actually i was just
gonna say it's annoying that that dance
accompanies you ymca but they don't the
song itself doesn't tell you to do that
with your hands that's true that's true
they're not forcing you whereas this is
like a little bit softer now a little
bit louder now you gotta like it's
annoying yeah the wave is annoying do
you hate when there's their song like
put your hands in the air and wave them
like you just don't care do you ever
like feel the wave is annoying yeah
also uh sweet caroline but i do it i do
you know what's the most annoying part
of sweet caroline
yeah yeah
well that's what what are being so we're
being so negative you know one of the
funniest things jonah did let's make it
more positive i remember when jonah used
to sing that song when it was we do
karaoke
and instead of pom pom bomb he go [ __ ]
you dad
i always think of that now
it was one of the funniest things and
it's something that's so funny that it
like has stayed with me this whole
because he didn't have a bad
relationship with his dad yeah it was
just like a fight shout out to rich
fellas it's just a really funny random
thing to say oh man it made me laugh so
hard still does
[ __ ] you dad good times never because it
was so like positive and buoyant like he
and he did it with a big smile
joe gatto joe gatto man what and what a
great guy god it really does it did seem
like you knew him
very surprising that you didn't know i
know but he seemed like a ketchup it
seemed like one of the life is short
episodes that's just more of a ketchup
oh well it makes sense from my end i
guess just because like we said i've
been watching so much of him and i just
i i felt like i knew him but for him
you know he had much less exposure to me
although that's true but he he has such
a natural people-person quality to him
or is this an arrogant assumption um
that he because i knew i knew he had
been listening to the show oh i listened
to the show oh really in fact he reached
out on instagram i don't want to out him
this might sound lame but like it was so
flattering i was it meant a lot to me
that he i think he must have heard us
talk about how much we love the show and
so he reached out and he was like hey i
saw he was following me on instagram and
we like chatted on instagram that's cool
yeah
yeah he he i think likes the show i
think i i don't want to
if he's listening now and he's like what
was he talking about
i've been listening
anyway he's we love you joe and um and
and
sal i mean murr and and um you're next
quinn i mean like brian those guys have
to come on so if they're listening which
they should be they should be supporting
a fellow joker it's he's such a
fascinating guy because he's like such a
guy's guy you know he comes across as
such a guy like a guy from but he has
such sensitivities
and he doesn't um he knows nothing about
sports or
music and he doesn't drink or do any
drugs or isn't that amazing how why he
doesn't drink yeah yeah really moving
he's such a like but there's something
so sensitive about him too and like and
compassionate
not drinking or doing drugs now you know
he's in his 40s
to me that's much less impressive i know
than avoiding it during those years
those like insecure years it's true the
fact that he was as amiable and fun and
gregarious
then like in high school and college
totally sober
speaks to how naturally confident he is
totally i mean that that's an incredible
amount of confidence required also to do
all that sober i know to do those bits
to like [ __ ] with people i know that's
wild well he kind of alluded to this i
don't know how directly he addressed it
but he said i wondered if because he
suffered that kind of a loss when he was
younger that things took on a whole new
meaning i mean like
the world was he saw it through a
different lens um and
he had more courage i guess i mean to do
things like that like it this the stakes
uh it just everything is the stakes are
lowered you under ort's just like in his
dna yeah like his dad was this amazing
salesman and right right i mean he has
that
i'm not discounting no no i'm sure it's
a combination yeah thereof right from
that that stock that yeah i'm just gonna
go up make the sale talk to you like
i've never been scared on impractical
jokers all four of those guys are like
they're all extremely
brave in their own way but
i would say he more than the others has
a fearlessness that is
it it's like unparalleled you know he
that guy
does does the craziest [ __ ] and he does
it like he commits
so much to the most absurd things that
he gets away with almost anything that's
true people just eat it up accept it
yeah i think the reason that show is as
effective as it is is because it's the
perfect combination of
funny and loving yeah yes like they love
each other and they're nice people
but if they weren't as nice and if they
like messed with people strangers more
in like a meaner way yeah i don't think
that show would be nearly as good well
it's funny because i've seen like
different
incarnations of that show like different
attempts at that there was one on
recently i don't want to mention by name
but i i i think was comedy central
they've tried that that formula a few
other times and it usually has an
element of that of kind of like
snarkiness or like net you know even
like punk had a little bit of that was
like you start to feel bad for the for
the person at a certain point but you're
right they never veer into that that's
the genius of the shooks those guys are
so nice if anything they tease
themselves they make fun of me
i love how he makes fun of murph for
referring to his property as his
property instead of his yard like his
property
it's such a that's such a subtle thing
but i know what he's saying it's really
funny i know well that's the thing those
guys have i really share maybe this is
an arrogant thing to say like i really
like them because i feel like i share
such a so we both share such a similar
sense but that's such a great thing and
friendship you know where you can
bust each other's balls and you can
tease each other and and know each
other's weaknesses and sometimes exploit
those weaknesses and it's never mean
it's like all done in love well
especially now like when so many people
can't take jokes the way they used to
like it's so nice that those guys can
take jobs and it's such a good thing to
like remind the world that it's okay to
do it's okay to be like offend your
friend a little bit exactly you know it
it it
helps you grow i think and it and and
like you discover the boundaries of your
own humor
you know it's like if i i i they all
have their line but like it's much
further than most people's lives oh my
god like they do [ __ ] during funerals i
know and that was a funny story
the story about the uh the long game bit
he did with
valerie signed him up for all those
things
over the course of years
that is so funny and like knowing full
well that he probably wouldn't be there
for the reveal i know that's a true
uh clown and i mean that in the most
like affectionate way that's somebody
who just has a spirit of like values
humor and uh there's a over everything
else you know there's like a real
pla such a playfulness to him yeah oh my
god he is he is like a true
child
in in the best way
yeah in the play in the most playful
like pure way he just like love he lives
for the joke it's like some of those
people who like never fully and i mean
this in the best way too that you never
fully grow up you know you still you
always retain that childhood thing you
know that like
fun like playful yes in a sense you know
qualities that most people associate
more with children yeah um but should be
valued in adults
yes should be like
uh
cultivated should be encouraged and i
think play it i think it also makes the
well we've talked about this it makes
the best actors i think joe is actually
really great i think they're all like i
know he couldn't really accept that
compliment but i completely agreed with
you yeah he he really is oh yeah that's
what they're doing in in in these bits
like they're of course he's completely
convincing yeah also impressive that he
sleeps with six dogs in his bed yes how
i know how do you get up to pee i don't
know how you do that without waking one
of them up
that's i mean that's commitment
he i think he loves dogs more than
anyone i've ever met
so uh yeah which is also indicative of
like house what a sweet like sensitive
person he is i like how he has that
family like motto that they all or
mantra that they repeat like um if you
know what it is but they refer to
themselves as kind and brave yeah and
it's like of course
what better words to describe that guy i
know and i'm sure his kids are going to
be kind and brave i know things to
aspire to yep and things that he really
you're right really embodies let's read
a letter okay
this is from ileana chase sorry do you
um make it extra crinkly when you grab
it just to like show that you're getting
something from me subconsciously did i
did it sound like that i've thought this
before but i've never said anything oh
really wait let me try to do that again
i'm going to try it again take two let's
read a letter
no maybe it's just it's paper i mean
like it's paper paper i mean here's me
trying to do it like soft is that the
note it was two i'll do it stopped okay
take three let's read a letter
your turn was soft too
that's soft okay okay this is thrilling
okay
uh
iliana hopefully joe's not listening now
that's a show you guys are doing ileana
chase
subject life is short let's travel
exclamation point mark dear justin and
christian we would like to start by
saying that we love your podcast we
we discovered it in june this year when
my husband
and i started traveling through the
united states oh that's the we
that's the we you and your brother
christian have accompanied us in our
travels for three months and 20 states
so far not counting canada that's
amazing three months that's so cool we
have caught up on almost every single
podcast and discovered new ones thanks
to your guests i.e minnie and rob well
we joined the peace corps wow a year and
a half ago good for you guys um but due
to the pandemic they've been delaying
our departure to thailand so we decided
to travel for a year sounds like a good
cause i want to go to thailand i know
i know
beautiful there me too you don't both
have to want to go to thailand and
admire people who are in the peace corps
we sold everything we owned and packed
our car with our kayaks and essentials
wow they sound cool they sound very cool
yeah we embarked on this adventure of a
lifetime because life is too short after
we finish our us trip we'll be going to
costa rica and then south america okay
ileana hold on one second i'm gonna
recommend something to you to do in
custody because because i know you'll
love it i hope it's still there at the
base of mount arenal which is a
beautiful volcano there in the in the
mainland uh there is a place called
rancho margo it's um
it's a sustain it's a sustainable
they call it a resort but
um they grow your own food you cook your
own you'll love it um check it out
rancho margot and then south america got
it i would which i was just talking any
recommendations for that no but i'm
dying to go to uh have you ever been to
uh south america remember when i planned
that machu picchu trip um no manchester
i planned a trip uh after uh a breakup i
was oh discover myself and um
i can't
i cancelled it when i
i learned in more detail of the bathroom
situation
embarrassed to say this not not the
physical
um
difficulties no oh
of the climb that too brian our mutual
friend brian greenberg uh told me that
about like altitude sickness and stuff
and i started researching that a little
bit um so that that worried me but that
wasn't a total deterrent the so you
canceled the trip you stayed home and
watched impractical jokers and stuff
exactly exactly it was you know what i'm
glad i did
back to ileana keep bringing joy and
laughter to our hearts ileana and
michael chase p.s we just saw lady of
the matter last week it was so funny yes
yes way to bury the lead
um
thank you ileana and and michael
uh okay and she has yes would you rather
would you rather be stuck in a world
where you are famous but you cannot be
creative
someone else dictates what you do and
how you act or be able to create with
freedom but never get the credit for
your work or get recognized we've had
versions of this before
yeah excuse me um
we've had versions of this before it'd
definitely be for me
because i
i and i am i there are elements of being
famous of having recognition that are
definitely in the moment enjoyable and
do something for the you can feel them
make you feel momentarily but would you
say the negative components might
outweigh the positive components 100 i
would say for sure and it's only having
gone through it had i not had a taste of
it i might struggle with this question a
little bit more because there was a time
where i really coveted the trappings of
fame and all that and and it's
embarrassing to admit but it's true but
having experienced it i would also say
also in this scenario you can't be
famous and creative yeah so that is
dictates what you do then it's a
no-brainer oh yeah and for someone to
dictate how you act i don't even know
how that would work
well i guess it's a version of um
you know if you're on a reality show or
something something in something oh yeah
i guess so hey will you be i think
that's kind of how they direct those
things like hey
they manipulate you but i guess but i
guess
you know as a reality contestant
unless you really want to be famous i
think there's a and which i think a lot
of them
are really driven by um i think this
question is it's easier to answer for
you having
tasted
some of that already yeah like you said
yeah i can answer it almost like on your
behalf because i've seen right i've seen
the negative components
even though i haven't really experienced
them
have yeah you have and you've also
experienced the like i would say a
negative part is like people saying bad
things about public people you don't
know saying that having a negative
opinions of you you've experienced that
i i
that's something to aspire to i think
getting to a point where
you care more about and focus more on
the positive things being said than the
negative that's that's i think that's
hard to do it is i aspire to that too
that is really hard to do because i
think there might be a part of i don't
know how
deep i'm capable of getting on this but
like i think there is
a part of me that feels like undeserving
of that you know um it's the imposter
syndrome so when i read something
negative it just kind of confirms like
oh yeah see i'm not right or i'm not
supposed to be doing it or whatever
it confirms some subconscious feeling
that i have something to talk about
therapy that's right um thank you eliana
yeah and um
congratulations on your cool life yeah i
know that sounds so fun uh yeah and good
luck noble i know fun and noble that's
the way to do it peace corps like joe
gatto fun and noble hey nice this is a
good letter for this episode it really
is and that was a good um
that that was a good wrap around what
would you call that a a reach around
yeah it was a great reach around joe
would like that joke um also if you guys
would like to write in the show joe
gatto that was a joke gato
sorry about that our email address is
life is short at wondery.com
and uh we will talk to you all next week
and check out impractical jokers if you
haven't um
we love joe and we love you guys and um
thank you for listening talk to you next
week
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
uh life of short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian law it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie v allen and the
senior producer is michelle
executive producer audio engineer
there's sergio enriquez and the audio
engineer we just said and now the
executive producer marshall louis the
banner under which we all do this the
umbrella is wandery
[Music]
that's true this is a blimp isn't that
true
that's true a nutshell is not no it only
contains one thing yeah where and a
blimp only contains one thing what's in
a blimp do you even know um i don't know
it's helium and it's not just helium
right i don't know
but i don't know
doesn't that seem like something you
should know but who knows that what's in
a balloon i wish they were
it'll be like it's things on like blimpy
sandwiches i know what's in a balloon
it's like whatever you want
what's in a blend pizza once in a place
the second option is what's what's best
in a plenty
you